any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable in magic
welcome everybody to the into the
impossible podcast
I am your fearful host these days Bryan
Keating co-director of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination at
UC san diego and today it's a great
pleasure to be joined by Assemblymember
Todd Gloria all the way from way north
near the border I don't think the border
starts there but in Sacramento I've
known Todd on and off for almost a
decade that might be more than a decade
and you know I'm very very flattered
that she came on the podcast to talk
about some big ideas that you have for
the future of San Diego so I was hoping
you'd start by introducing yourself
telling your audience a little bit about
you for those who might not be familiar
sure well Ryan thank you for the
opportunity I'm grateful a chance to
have a conversation and I am in
Sacramento today I think this fight
could be unlike any other conversation I
have in the capital so thanks for being
the spot in my day my name is Todd
Gloria I always tell people I'm a
third-generation San Diego which means
that I know where our city has been and
the son of a maid in a gardener which
means I know how hard it is to make ends
meet and the town is expensive to San
Diego and important they have a vision
for I'd like to take our community
namely I'd like us to embrace the fact
that we are a major American city a
global city and that we act accordingly
I come to that vision based on a career
in public service
grew up in Claremont Graduate from
Madison High School attended the
University of San Diego worked for the
county of San Diego and Health and Human
Services worked for congresswoman Susan
Davis for many years started on our
Housing Commission was elected to the
City Council in 2008 served two years as
council president did eight months as
mayor after the resignation of Bob
Filner and now I'm in my fourth year in
the California Legislature where I serve
as the assembly of some adjourn subjects
our housing transportation
infrastructure and climate and those are
the things that sort of animate what I
want why I want to be the next mayor of
San Diego fantastic so what I'd like to
talk to you about specifically are those
that pertain to the future as a
said we should all be interested in the
future we're gonna spend a lot of time
there in particular at UC San Diego we
had kind of envisioning the future of
San Diego near 2049 last year that was
held also coincided with the two hundred
and fiftieth anniversary of San Diego
which I didn't know it doesn't look a
day over two hundred to me but but
apparently that was that I'm showing
some scenes from a magazine article I
think in San Diego magazine for those of
you who are watching on YouTube what
will what will San Diego look like in
2050 nine so that will be in a little
bit longer period of time than we looked
at with that UC San Diego last year but
I want to start off with this kind of
image behind us and you really mention
that you know San Diego's this major
metropolitan area and I want to get some
idea of what your vision is for the
future of San Diego as an attraction we
we all know and love it well first of
all you know some of my friends say
don't don't ask people you know why more
people should move to San Diego because
we can't afford you know it's terrible
here the weather is awful but what why
should why should people come here and
what do you see as as the future of San
Diego as an attraction both holistically
in terms of all the wonderful strengths
and opportunities we offer here and and
also in terms of some challenges that we
must overcome in order to make the
vision that you aspire to a reality yeah
it's a good question um you know I think
San Diego sells itself in a lot of ways
obviously we have incredible climate we
have a beautiful natural resources just
the space that we actually move around
is just gorgeous that's you know really
comparable elisany where else I I love
the fact that I have a job where on a
daily basis I interact with 80 people
who represent all the other parts in
California and I'll just say that when
they know where I'm from the reaction is
almost uniform ah I love San Diego yeah
listen you know we're doing pretty good
on your average Tuesday and but beyond
that beyond what kind of God blessed us
with is what has shaped up around and
you work for one of our premier you know
institutions one of our great job
creators one of the things that sets us
apart with
fortune to have UCSD and then also have
SDSU and USD and Point Loma Nazarene and
some incredible community colleges what
I'm trying to say is that we are a place
of innovation of opportunity I think
that's one of the things that's
interesting about San Diego and I've
always sort of chalked it up to our
military in the sense that it's a very
open community you know if you a
newcomer in San Diego you can get
involved in are still civil society
pretty quickly you know you don't have
to spend generations toiling before you
can get on the Chamber of Commerce board
or be a part of any of our sort of civic
institutions we're very open community
and as a result I think we benefit from
a lot of innovation and a lot of
interesting folks that are attracted
here and stay here in terms of what is a
challenge going forward let me I didn't
finish that thought I point out that
military uh we have such a concentration
of military and and orders usually are
just for a couple years of time so we're
used to turn over here and do new people
and so we we welcome that we're not
we're not fearful of them and we were
able to integrate them quickly and so
that is I think prevented a lot of our
economy and it made us a place that's
very welcoming for for outsiders who
quickly become yes with regard to our
challenges you know there are a lot but
I think our biggest challenge is that
too often we see ourselves as a small
city a small town of a big city and the
way that plays itself out is that we're
in my judgment a world-class City
without a world-class transportation
system that we are the fifth largest we
are the eighth largest city in the
United States between the fifth largest
homeless population in the United States
and these are all symptoms of I think a
general desire to not be la which I'm
happy that we are not but it is often in
that definition of what we are not it
doesn't define who we are
and what I want us to be is a global
world-class city where everyone has the
opportunity to try yeah I always say we
have great raw materials here and you
know you're running for you know one of
the hardest jobs in the world I would
say because with great with great
expectations come even greater
expectations you know with great with it
with a great sort of back
that we have and despite our challenges
obviously people hold you to high
account because you're given a lot of
great resources to work with I also
always say that you know the easiest job
in the world is San Diego weather
forecaster the hardest job in the world
the San Diego sportscaster I believe and
maybe this would change under the next
mayor whoever he or she may be but but I
believe were the only major city since
Cleveland won a championship a few years
back and NBA we've never won a major
sports championship so let's turn to
sports entertainment before we turn to
technology innovation medicine etc do
you have a specific vision for San Diego
in terms of entertainment sports you
mentioned we're not LA of course that
comes with you know with great with
great joy for many of us but but we also
don't have the access to their
entertainment industry
what what do you see is this future of
San Diego and entertainment comic-con
etc and sports particularly for those of
us who are long suffering Padres fans
well I think the future is what we want
to make it and again under that sort of
heading of wanting to be a world-class
City a community that embraces its size
and acts accordingly you know I think
that the hallmark of that is world-class
art entertainment it is often a feature
of professional sports I'm grateful that
we have the Padres here we have some
interesting soccer teams that are
operating here I'm anxious to see SDSU
take over a new stadium in the
not-too-distant future I'm hopeful that
we'll have a new sports arena in the
not-too-distant future I think all of
these things adds the quality of lives
again our our weather's pretty good but
we can't get a buy just our good looks
we have to have lots of other things in
town to attract to maintain our
residents and obviously sports play an
important part of that
I'd like to enlarge that conversation
fine and to make sure that we also talk
about sports for people who are not as
talented as those who play on some of
our professional teams and what I mean
by that is to make sure that our public
parks and recreation facilities are up
to par should not to be
lofty standards you know when I look at
some of our regional parks I'm thinking
about you know our historic buildings
about ballpark our our seawall in
Mission Beach you know many of these
sort of iconic locations that we have
for recreation they can match our
expectations as a community and actually
I think diminish our ability to take
advantage of the tourism that likes to
come to San Diego and help us pay for
road repairs police officers library
hours so I think a broader vision of
sports to be inclusive of our
neighborhood recreation facilities is
pretty important you mentioned
entertainment I'm glad that you did
because an observation I have is a state
assembly member a couple of years ago
the state understood that we were losing
a lot of entertainment in particular
filming to other communities to other
states to other countries the stuff that
typically was done here in California
and we passed a film tax credit that has
been successful in bringing a lot of
this production back to California what
my observation is is that we could
probably do better and tracking some of
that work here to San Diego we already
tracked them for you know weekend every
summer for comic-con and we have to keep
comic-con we must expand our Convention
Center and we'll have to the next mayor
will have to have one on their agenda
but if we can attract them for that we
can attract them to stay longer periods
to do a film production here because
well that's kind of cool we like really
16 Top Gun and other things get filmed
in our community it also creates a lot
of jobs and these are jobs that are
actually in many cases decent pain so I
think we should to take advantage of the
tax breaks that we are already providing
to some of these film companies and make
sure that they take the road down the
five down here to San Diego to employ a
lot of sandy Aegon's I think that would
be good for our community to be good for
our brand and help us elevate ourselves
that with high status I'm hoping to
elevate us to long as I go back to LA
just kidding I'm here that's true yeah
but the grips in the in the dolly people
there sandy aegon
deserved work to know that's true that's
absolutely true so I want to talk now
about something you briefly touched upon
which is you know kind of one of the
hallmarks of San Diego is as a tech hub
as an innovation hub as a university
town
with all those wonderful universities
I've been honored to speak at all major
universities in San Diego for a while I
was invited to speak at Sea World they
used to have anheuser-busch university I
was never invited to that but I'll leave
that off my transcript
but I do want to ask a question about
one of our strengths is healthcare and
we have huge new hospitals growing up
here in La Jolla and Hatton already
developed Jacobs Alton etc Moores Cancer
Center and then in downtown or Central
City Heights area and and in the mission
area what what prevents a lot of people
of course is the extreme high cost of
health care and my my question for you
is what powers does the mayor really
have i under his or her influence to
actually effectuate these improvements
it seems like a lonely job to me and and
I'm curious you know we'll get to
personal stuff later and semi personal
advice to your former self but what what
authority does the mayor have in reality
for those of us who may not understand
what what can the mayor what can he or
she actually do to lower the price of
healthcare or improve access to
education or sports etc can you explain
that for us sure I mean so a lot of it
is indirect because I think what you're
alluding to is the fact that much much
of that is that some of the direct
jurisdiction of the city of San Diego
but from my view the mayor of San Diego
is the biggest bully pulpit in our
region and as a consequence if you care
about those issues you can use that
bully pulpit to drive change even if you
may not have the legal responsibility or
jurisdiction of it you can still work on
it so in the case of education you know
if you're trying to build a world-class
City you can't do it without high
schools you will not be able to retain
workers for much longer than it takes
for them to get married and start having
children before they'll leave and so you
have to be invested in it and I respect
the role to behalf of a separately
elected school board who's responsible
for overseeing our schools and public
instruction that doesn't mean that
there's a wall between us for which we
can never communicate in fact I think
quite the opposite we should be in the
business the same how can we collaborate
to make things better I did a little bit
of this when I was on the City Council
when we were working on creating our new
Central Library we made the decision to
clewd a high school inside the public
library so you have a city of San Diego
a said the library with a public charter
school inside of the library
collaboration that actually made the
project financially feasible but
actually made it work better because you
have hundreds of young people who are
accessing the many resources in that
central ID and you see it over and over
again with the city investing in
improvement in school fields it might be
decomposed granite if it weren't for the
city's investment dollars to convert
integer and then make it a community
asset at night and on the weekend so
there are plenty of ways that we can
collaborate but I think that that bully
pulpit is really important and the same
is true on health care you know the San
Diego's obviously has a very large
number of employees over 11,000 we
negotiate healthcare contracts for our
employees and as such we can help
influence the local market but I'm
taking a cue from my current job which
is that the mayor of San Diego does
carry some cloud up here in Sacramento
and when we're looking at expansion of
healthcare or reduction in rates or
other kinds of things that might make it
a little bit easier to make sure you
stay healthy the city of San Diego
should weigh in on some of these issues
because it directly impacts the 1.3
million people that live in our city and
so I'm hopeful in taking my experiences
here in the legislature and make sure
that I don't forget them when I'm at
City Hall and then I use them to the
benefit because as you mentioned it's
not just about potholes in public safety
those are both important things but it
is also about the other things that make
up our quality of life that's education
that's health care that's opportunity
that's work force development things
that again may not be legal
responsibilities in the city but I think
there's a moral responsibility for the
mayor to lead on those things and thank
God you get a bully pulpit that allows
you to do that yeah so that's that's
fascinating all a lot wrapped into that
I wonder as you as we were speaking you
know what influences you've had in terms
of shaping your leadership philosophy
have you have you other books or they're
kind of tools that somebody you've been
in civil service basically your whole
adult life and I know from personal
information you are always interested in
this even as a high school student where
can people find out more about you know
the properties of using the bully pulpit
as you say I think that's common to
every every position
from you know from local politics all
the way up to international politics
what sorts of leaders have shaped your
philosophy as an aspiring mayor of the
city of San Diego well there's been
quite a few but there's probably no when
is more important to me than congressman
Susan Davis I met Susan I was 14 years
old and you're right you know I was
always interested I was the nerdy kid
who would watch c-span for fun even I
just thought that was interesting it was
my kind of sport and what I always tell
young people and I had the chance to
talk with them is to figure out what
your passion is and pursue it if you can
make a career out of it that's fantastic
I love that I've been able to spend my
entire adult life waking up every
morning just to make my hometown a
better place to live that that feels
like a blessing and hopefully you know
what for me doesn't feel like work and
hopefully when people pick up on the
passion and excitement when they
interact with me and they see me do the
work but meeting Susan at 14 years old
helped to take that that energy and that
interest in that passion and actually
put it towards public service and so I
learned a lot from her and I think that
I can encapsulate it in maybe one thing
that she said which is that if you're
doing this work well you're listening
more than you're talking yeah I'm pretty
much failing at that right now you're
the guest
I would say that it goes back to
experiences of the county when I was
working in Human Services in Social Work
you know so much of this work time is
about listening to people understanding
what which of their needs are not being
met what problems they're experiencing
and then doing my best to connect them
to resources to connect them to solution
in a day that's still what I do right
for a living and that's what I would do
as mayor so Susan's a early imprint on
my my leadership development is
indelible and I'm very grateful because
I think she does this work with extreme
class and with extreme authenticity
which i think is really important and
I'd note that as she has announced her
retirement in Congress you couldn't find
a single person on higher side of the
head on to say anything bad about and
that's and that's really a testament to
how she carried herself beyond that
there's been a ton of things I was a
harry s truman scholar and in college
became enamored with the former
president and sort of
beginnings to risings a position of
great responsibility in acting with
decisive decisiveness I mean there are
tons of things that have involved
informed my leadership style but it
really goes back to Susan's admonition
about about being present about
listening about being humble about being
authentic I hope that's what I bring to
this work there I think there's a famous
stoic philosopher who said you know God
or if you prefer the universe gave you
two ears and one mouth and that's the
ratio he should use except when you're
on podcast I think so next question is
when I put also to your competitor which
is the role of Science and Technology in
a Gloria administration for example
would you have a science adviser and no
I'm not volunteering but would you have
a technology adviser would you have Task
Force how would you capitalize in sort
of the center of innovation that we have
here with these expectation that you'll
make it more democratic small D and
easier to monetize that make it more
affordable et cetera to really liberate
this nuclear force that we have here in
San Diego yeah well I would expect to
and I can tell you that that's been my
part of my leadership style unlike the
current occupant in the White House I
don't believe I have all the answers
and I think a good leader surrounds
himself with people that have good
information have practical experience
and that you can learn from when kovin
19 broke out you know I quickly
assembled a team of public health
professionals including a few folks from
UCSD to help advise me you know I'm not
an epidemiologist but I've been asked to
make decisions based on epidemiology and
there's only so much you can get from a
staff before you need to be able to talk
to people in confidence and with trust
to be able to understand what does this
mean and what is your impact was it and
it bounce those ideas off of other folks
so you're not just working with one
person's opinion I think that's
important for a host of different issue
areas particularly if it's not within
your professional skill set I don't give
a responsibility to the public to have
good advice from folks who are
knowledgeable and right I would say that
that's particularly important in the
SPECT in the space of technology when I
was elected to the City Council the city
had not made major investments in its IT
infrastructure and
as a consequence much of what was being
done at the city was being done with
antiquated systems and old programming
language that basically meant the city
was fitting a whole lot of money on very
inefficient systems
I guess my way I try to explain to
people is you don't always get to cut a
ribbon when you buy a new software for
the city and as a consequence it often
gets neglected having a team of
technology advisors to make sure that
we're making wise decisions is pretty
darn important we have a department in
the information technology but again
when they're providing staff
recommendations having subject matter
experts to consult is pretty darn
important and that's why we hope to do
on this and a host of other issues as
I've done in the past as I'm currently
doing during clopin 19 pastic so the
last thing I wanted to talk before we
get onto the questions I asked all my
guests not just those that are aspiring
to positions in civil service is is
where I believe that you and your
competitor are very much opposed and
that has to do with transportation
perhaps and what are called micro
mobility devices these are scooters and
bikes and so forth where do you see that
playing out how big a role do you see
these having in an era where you know
one of the pieces behind me is from San
Diego Magazine envisions the interstate
8 as being turned in and in 30 years
from now into a giant bicycle lane you
know one big giant bicycle lane I don't
know if you envision it quite the same
way but how do you view the the place of
these micro mobility devices and in
other ways in technology distribution
and access given that we're going to
have this trolley system which will come
up to our backyard here at UC San Diego
yeah well it kind of goes what I should
say to moment ago about technology
inserting the glint in it in the case of
micro ability in San Diego I think it's
been a case study of what poor
leadership can do with new technology
you may know that these devices here in
San Diego pretty much overnight and
we're essentially regulated for over a
year and as we know what anything when
it's unregulated you're gonna have
things that are not community enhancing
I think we've seen a lot of that
behavior what was interesting is when
the city finally got around to
regulating them many of the concerns of
people
expressing to me what quit were
addressed and so I guess that's a lesson
for again not taking a back seat when it
comes the innovation to technology it's
actually leaning in and figuring out how
to take this stuff and actually make it
better make it better for our community
in the in this in the case of micro
mobility you know I have been interested
in making sure that we can have these
options available to Sandy against right
now I think that sandy has really only
have lunch points when it comes from
getting from A to B that's your car my
vision would be where you have many good
options for how you want to get from A
to B and that would be walking safely on
sidewalks that are not busted biking
safely through your community where
you're not worried about getting killed
being able to take quality public
transit that comes frequently is priced
appropriately and goes where you want it
to go
and yes you can drive your car too if
that's what's appropriate under the
circumstances we don't have that system
ma'am but if we can have that system and
so the visual behind you I think is
doable it won't be doable during my a
minute mayoral administration but I'll
have a responsibility for laying the
groundwork to actually get us there I
think of it like this every time you and
I may go to Balboa Park I think we think
about the people who are wise enough to
set that aside and make an investment
over a hundred years ago with great
reverence we're grateful that they did
the hard work Vince that we can benefit
from it now I think the next mayor needs
to lay the framework and foundation for
a world-class transportation system so
that 100 years from now or maybe even
just 20 or 30 years from now people will
say gosh I'm so grateful they made this
investment my commute isn't as hellish
as it could have been I was able to get
home in time to see my kids and have
dinner with them or I just was able to
to see reduce my carbon footprint
because climate change is real these are
all things that are possible if the next
mayor chooses the lead and not the
benignly and they collect things like
micro mobility turned a blind eye to the
need for bicycle safety we're not
engaged deeply on public transportation
that trolley line UCSD is no accident it
was 20 years worth of hard work I was
proud to lead on that when I was
chairing the Transportation Committee at
Sand dad and I'm gonna be anxious to be
there as mayor in 2021 when we cut the
ribbon
okay some women I want to now just wrap
up our conversation I know your time is
incredibly precious and I want to ask
the questions that I ask all my
from Nobel laureates to Pulitzer Prize
winners to artists painters etc
astronauts I had an astronaut on last
week not not the same astronaut I had
back in January whoo Jessica Mir a
graduate of Scripps Institution of
Oceanography while she was on the space
station that was a wonderful day for me
I want to ask you these questions that I
asked my guests and two of them involved
the deep future for you personally and
then for humankind which of course
includes San Diego and then I want to
ask you a personal question about advice
to your former self so I'll start off
with and they all relate in one way or
another to either a concept that is very
important to me and many other people
which is called an ethical will which is
to be a contra posed to the concept of a
material will which is much more
familiar where you have a plan for where
your material possessions will go but I
want to ask you is what kinds of things
are most important to you to give as an
ethical will something that you want the
future of humanity to take heart to and
to listen to in terms of ethical or
wisdom or advice that's pretty deep and
I that background is appropriate for the
question or going deep into the into the
future here no living life that I've
lived I'm mindful of the need for
inclusivity and and the real price is
paid when we don't have it I think you
see that play down right down within
rural communities where folks are
excluded bad things happen opportunities
are missed and so you know I think that
it is it is the difficult work to do -
to engage with people in an authentic
way and actually try and solicit
solutions that are better than it would
otherwise be but I I just I might as
well often when I'm at work that people
like me just a short while ago could not
have the job that I have and a lot of
progress and a lot of heartache and a
lot of sacrifices we made to lamia have
this opportunity and I guess what I
would say to the universe is that let's
not be so exclusive as to prohibit
people's participation in the process
let's open it up and
and see what happens but I I believe
deeply in the ability of humans when
empowered to do amazing incredible
things and I think often to the extent
that as it happens because we've
excluded them from the process I want to
be someone that's more inclusive the
next question has to do also at the
future is related relative to sir arthur
c clarke who's the namesake behind our
Clark center for human imagination and
he has in the famous movie 2001 a Space
Odyssey he has this famous iconic scene
with a monolith that's discovered by by
these future and past humanoids or
hominids if you will this monolith is is
sort of sent as a message to humanity
from a few past alien civilization so my
question to you is if if if you Tod had
a monolith a billion year long lasting
time capsule what material object or
saying or phrase or what have you
would you inscribe on it put within it
or leave for a civilization very unlike
our civilization today to discover a
billion years from how big is the money
these are quite these are quite
substantial this will not fit in the NS
UK it could it could be as big or small
as you like you know it's difficult
because something of that magnitude
would hopefully be more than what is
happening within my own lived experience
but you know one of the things I sort of
focus on and some of your folks may know
that I authored the city's climate
action plan which is at the time is a
landmark plan for reducing the city's
impacts on our climate at the time it
was criticized by some as being too
ambitious but here we are several years
later it is now basically
state-of-the-art you know other cities
the state of California other states
have followed San Diego's lead from this
climate action plan that I was honored
to author a number of years ago I think
we'd be putting that in the monolith
might be interesting in terms of what it
represents because that models won't be
going anywhere
and importantly it's about understanding
the concept that maybe what seems
foreign or too audacious or impractical
actually ends up being quite feasible
replicated and modded it just requires
the intestinal fortitude to be able to
persist and so I put that early climate
action plan in there as both symbolic of
what means from a persistence standpoint
but also as validation that it worked
and that there's actually something for
the monolith and there's a population
actually read the document of whatever
it reminds of this final destination
very good and so we've come to the end
of our conversation there are some may
be primates looking at this monolith
back and this is again what people in
1968 thought that the year 2001 would
look like so it's kind like Epcot Center
at Disney it's not exactly a great
representation of what it looked like so
the last question is more personal but
it could be as deep as you want to get
if if you choose and that has to do with
advice to your former self so the name
of this podcast is the into the
impossible podcast which is one of Sir
Arthur C Clarke's famous three laws of
the universe the first one is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and we have
a lot of Technology here in San Diego so
we're kind of a magic City that's one
reason the second law I mentioned to you
before we started for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
you've probably found that in your long
and varied political career and the last
one is the only way to find out what's
possible is to venture beyond into the
impossible and my question for you is
what you know fact of life or experience
or something seemed impossible for you
as a 20 year old as a 30 year old but
then all of a sudden you did it and and
saw that it was indeed possible well
what I do today you know if you'll
forgive the quick story I remember
sitting in my intro to Poli Sci class as
a senior at Madison High School in
Claremont and I remember the professor
speaking and he said you know there's
kids there's two things you can't be
if you want to be an elected official
number one is gay number two I don't
remember what number to us that was so
that he was authorized to work with
children would make such a statement
nobody think it wasn't a joke that was
like horrible and you know in a country
where we're all raised to believe that
if you work hard making be whatever you
want to be and then being that kid that
watching far too much seats been at that
point in time you know I didn't think
that what I ended up doing it for my
life was possible but that's actually
why I love our country our community San
Diego as I really feel like we can do
stuff and obviously I had a lot of great
mentors and people who said you know you
can do this and so I guess I live an
experience every day of thinking back to
that that kid in his desk in that hot
trailer bungalow at Madison High School
hearing that and thinking well then what
am I supposed to do not not that I'm
necessarily thought I'd run for office
but just really thinking that something
was not available to me because of who I
am was so countered at how I was raised
and I was just grateful to places to say
you know be persistent if I had any
advice to younger self it's that you
know you you you regret this that
there's the Gretzky thing you miss 100%
of the shots you don't take
my regrets would be for the
opportunities I didn't take advantage of
for the times I listened to those voices
that said no you can't do this because
the times I've gotten the courage to
step forward and step in we got the job
done and I just would hope that any
young person would be able to have those
external validators as well as that
internal monologue that says you can do
this because believe it you can and I
have lived that experience and and I'm
nothing special if I can do it you can
do it yeah so actually shortchange or
arthur c clarke there's actually a
fourth law which relates to the story
just told and that's he said that when
in elderly but distinguished scientist
says that something is possible she he
said he also she she is almost certainly
right but when an elder but
distinguished scientist or scholar or
expert says that something is impossible
he is almost always wrong so i think
that certainly is a case for for you and
your in your career i want to thank you
for sharing so much of your time
i am sorry
a little bit over but it's really quite
quite important I think for our
especially the tech and very
future-focused people in San Diego such
as those who listen to my podcast to
hear these visions and the comparison
and contrast between you and and and
your competitor barber Cree and I wish
you success and I thank you for keeping
a little bit politics free and hopefully
it wasn't too much nerding out for you
and I hope you enjoyed it I love dirty
now due date I button
thank you that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent
guests newest book send a screenshot of
your review to info at imagine UCSD edu
we appreciate hearing from you that are
always open to you suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
youtube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production for the
arthur c-- clark center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the University of California
San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco